we want to fact-check the president
statement that both sides are
responsible for the violence in
charlottesville video and photos from
the scene show protesters and counter
demonstrators fighting with each other
the white supremacist side appeared to
be more prepared for the unrest Paula
Reid covered the protests in
Charlottesville and witnessed much of
the violence Paula good morning good
morning
the rally hadn't even officially started
before clashes broke out in the park we
don't know exactly what kicked off that
violence but it's clear elements of both
sides showed up for a fight not all of
those people were neo-nazis believe me
Saturday's rally in Charlottesville was
one of the largest gatherings of white
supremacists in more than a decade
hundreds came the majority of them were
armed with guns and batons protected by
shields emblazoned with racist symbols
the counter protesters were
overwhelmingly unarmed but there were a
number of aunt Eva or anti-fascist
demonstrators who also used shields and
sticks and clashed with white
supremacists that they were largely
outnumbered you had a group you had a
group on the other side that came
charging in without a permit and they
were very very violent
it appears the worst violence came at
the hands of white supremacists James
fields Jr who traveled from Ohio to join
the neo-nazis was behind the wheel when
counter protester Heather higher was hit
and killed and a black man diandra
Harris needed eight staples in his skull
after he was severely beaten in a
parking garage in May a memo from the
FBI and Department of Homeland Security
warned of the persistent threat of
lethal violence from white supremacists
who were responsible for 49 homicides in
26 attacks from 2000 to 2016 more than
any other domestic extremist movement
yesterday the president insisted the
pictures didn't tell the whole story it
looked like they had some rough bad
people neo-nazis white nationalists
whatever you want to call them but you
had a lot of people in that group that
were there to innocently protest so I
only tell you this there are two sides
to a story we've reached out to law
enforcement for official estimates of
the crown size but for comparison the
last white supremacist rally in
Charlottesville had a few dozen KKK
members and approximately a thousand
counter protesters Charlie thanks Paula